Airlines everyone has had it it's not
just you
a new study the airline quality rankings
by Wichita State University and Purdue
University Erin I know those are two of
your favorite university places that
nobody calls nobody goes the other study
we used for was from Winnipeg and these
two random but these are legitimate
studies according to the critical
Atlanta or Chicago you know next week I
will go yeah next week I get sang from
Harvard or something anyway complaints
about the airlines are literally there
they're going through the roof not
literally
figuratively they're going through the
roof the complaints have gone up about
twenty twenty percent let's look at the
breakdown of the airline rankings and
some of this seems pretty obvious and
then some of this I think is kind of
surprising so in terms of quality the
best let's just look at the top five its
Virgin America JetBlue AirTrain Delta
Hawaiian and then at the bottom it's
American American Eagle sky less
expressed yet United I mean is there
anything else that we pay so much money
for that we all do everyone in the
country flies we all pay a ton of money
for it and get less of a pleasant return
is there anything like that
well one have people been bragging about
airline travel it just seems like well I
mean I literally traveled for comedy
probably every weekend every other
weekend I'm on a plane and it just seems
like they're all about the same I mean
Virgin America and JetBlue the reason
why everyone brags about them is because
you feel like the plane has been built
in the last couple of years it's like a
TV and it feels you know there's dance
music when you're bored virgin flights
yeah going into a club it is total Club
and it's like when you bored but I don't
know it just it just feels like honestly
the problem I have is not the Airlines
it's it's the people off people that you
know they're taking their shoes off and
they're sweaty gross feet are on the
chairs and this one family they just
they queued up Jungle Book for their
kids no no headsets just so well now
we're watching Jungle Book I don't know
it just seems like the humanity on the
plane is lowering the airlines
because that's kind of racist you think
that that's part of the thing though
that because we're not often locked in
with the group of people for five hours
so now if you're sitting there and you
can't you know do all your texting and
all that that you're really concentrated
on this group of people around you and
it makes you a little nuts well I I
represented Steven Slater the JetBlue
flight attendant release my client and
what can you tell people what he did
again real quick yes Steven Slater was
the guy on JetBlue and you know he was
mad as hell and he wasn't gonna take it
and so like he was like and some
passenger was mad and he picked up the
microphone and and said you're fabulous
I think something like and open the door
pulled the slide and grabbed a beer and
left the airplane greatest story of all
time but usually is this game you know
we were the gayest escape ever but what
you gotta understand is it was not about
Steven Slater was about the situation
that was set up it was an early morning
flight I think the flight left at 6:00
or 7:00 in the morning
so everybody's sleep-deprived
everybody's exhausted everybody gets to
the airport and you know you paid $118
or you paid 349 dollars and the person
next to you paid 118 and so you're mad
because you found out that they didn't
owe you paid 300 I only paid 118 and and
then you you know you over you know you
pack your bags and they go it's $25 so
you go screw that I'll carry it on in
the in the carry ons the overheads are
too small so they're doing and and if
they just create this system where you
cannot win where nobody can win and it's
it's it's it's about profits it's about
these mega businesses that are so big
they're hard to do profitable gasoline
goes up two cents a gallon and it costs
them twelve billion dollars and I'm
sorry my pet peeve the food yeah it's
like I fly a lot I fly at least twice a
month at transcon once a month and it's
like who conceives of this crazy why are
these odd combinations of piss
I think it's just like can I just have
like a salad with a little chicken on it
could I just have something simple and
they give you something that's so greasy
or so spicy or so you know it's just
and everything is red peppers I hate
peppers I burp them for seven years no
more red peppers people how you are
waking up in LA and landing in New York
and so it's you still have to be
positive you can still get across the
globe in like eight hours I mean it's
just really yeah wait there's Europe
yeah no I mean you know it's just it's
always it's always gonna be something I
like that they're there positive remarks
is where we're sort of landing on time
and the bags get to you and I'm like
again ya know cuz no one's checking them
they are literally shoving their bags in
the overhead and it's just you got a
drink you drink you can sit down your
chair get a cocktail slip a you know
vicodin or whatever take the next six
hours off yeah is this one of these
things that's just so systemic like from
the whole experience from the TSA I mean
if you go to JFK one of the biggest air
ports in the world just everything there
is so rundown the people barely seem
like they're paying attention you know
you're in Colombia it's like excuse me
Colombians yeah sorry I didn't mean to
offend the cartel it's is like the most
third-world airport if you're you know
you get your luggage they've rifled
through it you know it's just so
systemic at all levels from the TSA to
the to the planes themselves that are
falling apart I was on American a month
ago I mean literally the hand thing was
like falling apart is it just like
everything well there's just nothing can
be done right that was on an airline and
like the seat didn't go back and this
didn't do it and I'm really sorry it's
like I'll live with this I'm concerned
what in the engine you didn't fix
Lenovo's calm is the official outfitter
of the Reuben report I want to put you
in this slim fit shirt go to bonobos
calm enter code TRR to zero for 20% off
your next purchase